das ist mein am 21 november 2020
erschien auf einem kanal das video ich
bringe meinen hund sprechen bei ein
experiment es mhh wird dieses geräusch
damit verknüpften dass sie etwas zu
essen sprechen ja wohin soll ich schauen
mal so sophie ok schauen wir nach der
sophie was mit mir und wirst angst wovor
hast du angst knöpfe zu drücken um uns
das mitzuteilen was sie möchte hat die
meisten drauf mit diesen plan geh'n wir
aber noch einen guten schritt weiter ist
es möglich dass ein hund ein videospiel
spielt kann die minecraft spielen und
was würde sie machen oder zucker bauen
wenn man sie dabei alleine lassen würde
dieses video wird unterstützt von mir
selber in der video beschreibung findet
ihr den link zu meinem schnittkurs mit
dem er alles lernt was wird jetzt
schneiden von youtube urlaub musik oder
imagevideos braucht check den trailer in
der infobox gerne gratis ab nur noch
diese woche gibt es dicke vom 26 10
prozent rabatt auf alles mit dem tod von
sechs hinein
hodzic ich konnte einfach drei
nachkommastellen beim code einstellen
probiert gerne mal auch muss der spieler
interagieren mit der welt von minecraft
hauptsächlich durch acht eingaben aws de
für bewegungen leertaste zum spring
schiff zum sprinten steuerung zum
drucken links klickt zum zerstören von
blöcken runde rechtsklick zu umsätzen
von blöcken efis inventar die
mausbewegungen zum zielen und tee für
den chat aber warum auch immer haben die
entwickler von minecraft auch im jahre
2021 minecraft noch nicht ungerecht
gemacht also müssen wir jetzt kann der
youtuber liam thompson hat auf diesem
gebiet tatsächlich schon einige
pionierarbeit geleistet für
hundefreundliche tastaturen allerdings
nur mit zwei tasten einer für sound und
einer für vorwärts gehen womit die mine
niemals selbst kräften oder bauen lernen
könnte deswegen habe ich zusammen mit zu
viel über wochen hinweg einen
ausgeklügelten masterplan erstellt einen
masterplan der nicht nur die haptischen
limitierungen von hunden sondern auch
ihr einzigartiges lernverhalten
berücksichtigt und die steuerung von
minecraft komplett auf den kopf stellt
als erstes wäre aus unseren eingaben
alles raus was nicht unbedingt gebraucht
wird links rechts und rückwärtsbewegung
fliegt direkt raus sprinten und ducken
auch und auch auf den chat glaube ich
kann die man gut verzichten oder bleiben
nur noch weh leertaste rechtsklick
linksklick und vier buttons um die maus
nach oben links rechts und unten zu
bewegen da ich denke dass eine normale
maus generell nicht hundefreundlich ist
was findet vielleicht nicht wissen ist
dass man bei fast jeder tastatur die
einzelne tasten herausnehmen kann bis am
ende nur noch die über sind die man
braucht diese kleinen tasten ja so
nämlich ziemlich gut auf unsere
menschenfänger ausblick aber 100 wurde
braucht viel mehr platz unser pionier
liam thompson hat die einwohner kärtchen
auf die verbleibenden tasten geklebt
aber wir gehen auch hier noch einen
schritt weiter aber diese tasten hier
sind nämlich über einen gewissen steckt
mechanismus in der tastatur verankert
und genau diesen steckt - wenn ich jetzt
dreidimensionalen nach modellieren und
eine druckfläche drauf ankommt sind
[Musik]
jetzt genau so aus jetzt verraten das
teilt jetzt in den 3d drucker dass sie
geil aus das sieht richtig gut aus
[Musik]
jetzt die frage natürlich können wir
diese neuen bands draufsetzen vom
prinzip her sieht das nämlich sogar
relativ gleich aus ja das ist ziemlich
gut geworden hier gelungen das setup
steht ein großer monitor und eine
speziell modifizierte tastatur
hier soll ein hund minecraft lernen
jetzt kümmern wir uns um minecraft die
meisten funktionen sind sehr schnell
umgestellt aber die mausbewegung auf
tastendruck muss erstmal gescriptet
werden also in der theorie sollte das
jetzt funktionieren ich kann jetzt hier
mit wie einfach gehen das ist einfach
ist ein großer button
dann kann ich hier und dass das wildeste
mit diesem fallen hier die maus bewegen
das ist jetzt nicht so weich dass ist
immer abgehakt pro knopfdruck man kann
allerdings auch darauf bleiben man kann
jetzt glaube ich nicht zwei sachen
gleichzeitig drücken man kann immer nur
in eine richtung gehen aber ich kann
jetzt mal so ein schwein rüber gehen und
damit der taste kann nicht hauen easy
kräften kann man jedoch wieder weg hier
bewegt man die maus genauso mit den
gleichen buttons ein bisschen
experimentell kann man jetzt hier
ansetzen hier holzplanken draus machen
und sagt springen muss man allerdings
nicht ich habe das nämlich auf
automatisch bringen angestellt das geht
in minecraft es nervt nicht aber das
wird der mai auf jeden fall weiterhelfen
war schön die sonne richtigkeit und hab
das also debatten verspringen einfach
ersetzt durch scrollen durch scrollrad
man kann jetzt haben wir durch wechseln
indem man hier diesen button rück das
ist alles was man braucht um mannschaft
zu spielen
haha nein weil direkt an lab verbrannt
ihr denkt sich ich brauche das nicht ich
kann das auch so immer krieg wenn er
jetzt voll drauf wo mein gott das ist
eine gewisse genau wie macht man das
und mein gott sie es richtig erschrocken
weil sich etwas bewegt aber das ist gut
weil sie erkennen das ist ein richtig
guter story klasse und wir könnten ja
mal probieren auch das schwein aus aber
das ist schwierig und ich will das zwar
nicht ein bisschen vegetarier und den
baum ab als ob wir ein loch so wären wir
jetzt die angst genommen vor dem teil
jetzt muss man allerdings noch stumm für
jeden einzelnen befehl deren damit ihr
dennoch zu hören kann und das wird jetzt
erstmal ganz lang dass man die welt
erkunden
meist versuchen noch ein platz wo sie
ausbauen kann mal klassisch mal das
haben jetzt drei und mittlerweile kann
die man oft befehle jedes kommando
ausführen mein lauf und belohnen sie
dafür einmalig super und ähnlich wie man
zum beispiel sagt holzstöckchen und der
und dann losgeht und ein konkretes
objekt sucht vielleicht sogar in einem
anderen raum hat sie das an tag 5 mit
minecraft verknüpft wenn man jetzt also
sagt may münchen
[Musik]
tag 7 je mehr wir mal alleine lassen
desto mehr verselbständigt sich ihr
verhalten was am spannendsten ist dass
sie das spiel nicht so spielt wie ein
mensch das spielen würde bei dem die
glückshormone ausgeschüttet werden wenn
man holz findet ressourcen sammeln eine
neue landschaft findet in der man sich
im lager aufbauen kann im gegensatz dazu
hatten scheinbar ganz andere ziele wie
zum beispiel buddelt löcher wir haben
jetzt tag 14 des experiments und
mittlerweile zerstört meine ich nur
bürger sondern baut auch erste eigene
struktur hat sie gelernt werkzeuge zu
machen tag 19
nein entdeckt das feuer wir sind aktuell
kurz zuvor dieses experiment abzubrechen
einfach weil es echt beängstigend ist
und wir uns nicht sicher sind ob das
gesund für ihre psyche ist ich meine sie
hat heute morgen den hund gezähmt ja
gestern abend vergessen den pc aus zu
machen hat dann sind heute morgen die
mai dabei erwischt wie sie wieder was
gebaut hat ich habe mich am anfang echt
noch gefragt ob das irgendwie zufällig
ist dass sie dabei auch dass irgendwer
struktur hat aber mittlerweile werde ich
das gefühl nicht los als hätte die mein
gefühl für ästhetik
[Musik]
kaarst habt ihr mir das wirklich
geglaubt heute ist erster aprilia
frühaufsteher und warum habe ich
eigentlich eine männerstimme schreibt
gerne meine kommentare bewusst geworden
ist dass ich euch sol.de wahrscheinlich
schon am tank jamaika natürlich nicht
minecraft spielen also je nach kommando
nacheinander verschiedene aktionen
ausführen zu lassen das wird natürlich
funktionieren und damit hat sie auch da
william thompson aufgehört noch ein
ordentliches stück draufgelegt und
pionierarbeit geleistet meist dahin
gegangen wo noch nie ein hund zuvor
gewesen war aber selbständig spielen und
bauen kann sie natürlich nicht ich hoffe
ihr verteidiger der aprilscherz ich habe
es mir nicht nehmen lassen können dieses
gebäude das er gesehen hat ist übrigens
nur ein kleiner teil der riesigen open
world map von tom rpg einen großen
minecraft projekt das bereits seit zwei
jahren in arbeit ist ich hab ich mal
dass tori apg disco verlinkt wenn ihr
mehr infos möchtet und auch einen link
zu den bewerbungen wir suchen nämlich
bilder die bauen entwickler die
programmieren und kreative die quest
schreiben oder sowas 3d voxel art
mäßiges machen weil sie im ganz eigenen
items gibt wie zum beispiel dass hier
was ich noch selber gemacht wenn er bock
drauf habt alle infos und beschreibungen
auch zu einem schnittkurs gibt es alle
infos in der video beschreibung und ich
hoffe ihr falls heute nicht noch auf
mehr schlechter aprilscherz nächste
woche kommt übrigens zum ersten mal seit
einem jahr kein video wenn ihr das
darauffolgende dann nicht verpassen
möchte abonniert gern isst kanal und
aktiviert die glocke und dann sehen uns
das zunächst mal wieder macht's gut
[Musik]
klopp